I mean 19 years is like more that's
longer than people keep their kids in
their house Alan Pompeo is opening up
about her decision to leave Gray's
Anatomy after nearly two decades yes the
actress broke a lot of super fans Hearts
after announcing she was leading the
longest running medical drama in history
but during a recent appearance on the
Drew Barrymore show Pompeo insists she's
thrilled with her decision it's
super happy
incredible to me and and I love I've
loved
a lot of the experience listen it's just
I gotta you know I gotta mix it up a
little bit I'm 53 my brain is like
scrambled eggs God you're hot I have to
thank you I gotta do some news I gotta
do something new or I'm gonna literally
turn into like you know you can't choose
a New York Times crossword puzzle every
single day I mean 19 years is like more
that's longer than people keep their
kids in their house
until they're 18 and then they send them
off to college
so this is like me like going away to
college as for what she wants to do next
the actress is looking forward to
spending a lot more time with her family
I have a lot that I'm doing
um I have three kids
and
um so I take care of them and it's
really important for me to be around for
them and be more present for them I'm
going to do a limited series for Hulu
um in the spring which is a very cool
like kind of crazy true story now Pompeo
stepped into the role of Dr Meredith
gray back in 2005 and announced her exit
in an emotional goodbye letter to fans
just one week after season 19's fall
finale she explains I am eternally
grateful and humbled by the love and
support you have all shown me Meredith
gray and the show for 19 Seasons through
it all none of it would have been
possible without the best fans in the
world